So the project I'm going to talk about is
the Rosenwald School that was designed for
Hampton Institute, which was a teaching school,
an industrial training school in the Tidewater
region of Hampton, Virginia.
It was a project that exists in very few objects
within the archives.
So the primary thing that we have that represents
the project is this rendering perspective
that gives us a sense of what it would have
looked like had it been built.
When I first discovered and heard about this
project, I knew what the Rosenwald Fund was,
but I didn't know what the Rosenwald Fund
School program was.
It started in 1917 and ended about 1938, somewhere
around then.
But over that period, they built over 5000
schools for African American students, primarily
in the south.
And what was fascinating about the Rosenwald
fund in general was that it was monies given
by Julius Rosenwald who was a philanthropist.
He was Jewish, based in Chicago.
And the monies provided a number of things
beyond the school program, but he funded artists
and intellectuals and writers so people like
Marion Anderson, the singer, Ralph Ellison,
the novelist, Jacob Lawrence who did the Migration
Series.
But a large part of that fund also gave monies
for school construction.
In terms of the Rosenwald Fund, Booker T.
Washington started the fund, and it continued
really and grew at Tuskegee Institute.
Washington had this idea that if African American
communities could get some monies, part of
the money would come from Julius Rosenwald,
he would donate a third.
The communities would raise one third, and
local school boards would raise a third of
the funds, that the quality of the spaces
of education could be improved across the
south.
And so when you see the map of the school
building program, you realize the extent to
which these schools provided a service that
unfortunately under Jim Crow segregation was
not being provided, and the fact that African
Americans had to provide their own monies
even though they paid taxes in many of these
municipalities and to the state showed the
impact of Jim Crow segregation on education.
The original plan that Frank Lloyd Wright
receives from the Rosenwald Fund is a building
that is a U shape with an auditorium in the
front of that U shape.
And then you can see in the perspective that
it's more of a donut.
And what Wright does is he takes the auditorium
and pushes it to the back.
So by pushing it to the back, it opens up
an area that he describes as a patio and pool.
And this provides a place for children to
play to swim and this ties into his own experience
in designing buildings, school buildings,
playhouses, field houses for his clients,
his previous clients in the Chicago area and
in Wisconsin.
One of the interesting aspects that I found
out about the project is that Wright had very
progressive ideas about education and took
projects that he had done for his white clients,
fairly wealthy white clients and was willing
to adopt those ideas for African American
students.
But on the other hand, when you start to read
some of how Wright describes the project and
particularly the way in which he characterizes
African Americans as being childlike, enjoying
music and dance, bright colors.
He makes a reference to darkies.
There's a sensibility about Wright that also
starts to allow for kind of cultural hierarchies
that are certainly a part of that time and
could be understood as being sort of part
of the rationale about how civilization would
advance, which was often talked about as white
civilization without necessarily describing
it.
I think it's an important project because
it's one of the projects that doesn't have
a big footprint in the archive.
I mean, the archive is immense and enormous.
And this is a project that has very little
evidence.
What's fascinating was how it touched so many
other archives, the Rosenwald Fund archives,
Fisk University archives where the Rosenwald
Fund papers are being held and so it, to me,
showed how Wright was interacting with a lot
of major figures and institutions of the day
that were engaged in progressive education
and reform.